major news on two disputed midterm
election battles moments ago Democrat
Stacey Abrams ended her campaign and
said she cannot win but still wouldn't
call it a concession speech and her
hard-fought effort to overtake
Republican Brian Kemp in the Georgia
governor's race in fiery remarks Abrams
claimed democracy failed Georgia but
added she will no longer stand in the
way of officials certifying Kemp as the
winner
meantime in Florida they're doing it the
old-fashioned way tonight a hand recount
of votes underway to find out who won
the US Senate race in the state while
the governor's race appears over after a
machine recount and will be officially
certified next week Republican Ron De
Santis has declared victory for the
second time but the Democrat in that
race Andrew Gilliam retracted his
concession earlier this week and has not
conceded again vowing as of a couple
hours ago to fight on
we have Fox team coverage Peter Doocy at
the Broward County Election headquarters
again tonight with the Florida story but
we start off with the breaking news
Steve Harrigan in Atlanta with a very
confusing message from Stacey Abrams
could even Steve ray you're exactly
right this was a fiery angry speech by
Stacey Abrams and a little bit puzzling
as well she acknowledged that she lost
the governor's race in Georgia to Brian
Kemp Kemp got fifty point two percent of
the vote he had a lead of about 50,000
votes at a four million cast so Kemp
really just managed to avoid a runoff
election had he dipped under 50% that
would have happened next month he
avoided that Abrams till the very end
tried to gather and prove she had 17
thousand more votes coming she was
unable to do that so she gives her
concession speech and at the same time
says it's not really a concession here's
Abrams Watch who claims to represent the
people in the state ball week and his
hopes for election awesome
the People's Democratic right to vote
has been truly appalling so let's be
clear this is not a speech concession it
certainly didn't sound like a typical
concession speech either Abrams said in
a concession speech you're supposed to
say nice things about the race and the
other candidate she was having none of
that she said the state had failed
Georgia
she said democracy had failed the voters
in Georgia and she said there was voter
suppression across the state and she
blamed Brian Kemp who was the chief
election officer the Secretary of State
she said he ran a vicious campaign as
for Kemp himself who has been working
with transition officials earlier he
said Abrams was having temper tantrums
but his tone has changed dramatically
after this press conference by Abrams
Kemp said the issued the following
statement I appreciate her passion hard
work and commitment to public service so
what we're seeing now is really a bitter
end to a very bitter fight in a really
closely contested contest in Georgia
Abrams just 44 years old will now be a
private citizen but we could likely see
her in future races for governor or
senator in Georgia Matt back to you
Steve just to clarify there's no phone
call we we know of between the two
campaigns it also is lacking the
traditional phone call the Kemp team
learned about it from this press from
this concession speech which was not a
concession speech all right Steve
Harrigan live in Atlanta Steve thank you